hello welcome
i'm jeremy clark and here i'm going to
be giving a tour of go for the c-sharp
developer
and uh we can think of this as kind of a
tour that you take through an art museum
so
maybe you're following a tour guide
around for an hour
and they'll be pointing out some
interesting things maybe giving some
anecdotes here and there
but after that's over you probably want
to go around and look at stuff yourself
and maybe read all the signs and that
sort of thing
so this is an overview of some things i
find interesting about the go language
and if you want to get the slides and
code samples they are
available on github i'll go ahead and
paste in some resource links to the
slack
and to the chat
and that way you can take those home
with you
you can also hit my website at any time
jeremybites.com
and you'll find links to the resources
there as well
and if you want to follow me on twitter
i'm jeremy bites on twitter
so that's pretty much where i am online
so i want to start out by saying i am
not an expert and go
and this actually isn't designed for
experts it's designed for c-sharp
developers
and c-sharp has actually been my primary
language for quite a while
and why am i looking at go well
it's an interesting language i like
getting out of my comfort zone
kind of as frequently as possible
because that lets me see
how other languages and environments
deal with certain
problems and a lot of times there's
things that i can take into my primary
language and a lot of times there's
times where i say oh you know what
i was working with go and it's really
good at this problem that i have so
maybe i'll step out of my normal
environment and uh
go try that for a while so
my uh in my world why do i explore go
well
to see what kind of different
programming and pro approaches there are
and if there's some interesting things
that i can bring into
my environment now i am going to spend
most of the time in live
code so you get to watch me type as i
show
kind of some of the things i ran into as
someone who's used to c sharp
as i was learning to edit and deal with
the linter
and the compiler and some other things
so first just a little tiny bit about go
this is a language that was created at
google
and it was first released in march 2012
so it's been around a while
and a lot of times people will say well
you know this is good for
kind of server and programmer tools and
that sort of thing but it is in fact a
general purpose language
so it can be used for all different
kinds of things
and it does use a c like syntax i'll say
c ish and a few things about the
language it
is a statically typed language as
opposed to a dynamically typed language
like javascript
some things that were important when
they were designing it they wanted to
focus on
things like memory safety so things that
you don't get
in environments like c garbage
collection
is also something that's built into the
environment concurrency
is a big thing and in fact i'll be
showing some concurrency today
uh the um in order to
make a method concur and go you use the
go keyword so that's how important it is
and it was really focused on
runtime efficiency this compiles to
native executables on the system so
there's no runtime or interpreter
it goes straight to native executables
and it is cross-platform
so i'm running windows 10 today but i've
also done the same examples on mac os
and it runs on linux as well so it's a
good environment for that
today's topic these are some of the
things i'm going to hit on
and again as primarily a c-sharp
developer these are things that kind of
stood out
as interesting and made me go hmm i'd
like to
think about how this might impact my
day-to-day programming
one thing is that go does have a very
opinionated syntax
so for example where you put curly
braces is important
and we'll see that when we look at the
code we'll actually see all of these
things
another thing is unused variables
actually result
in a compile error so if you declare
something and don't use it you get a
compiler error
so that's a best practice you know don't
don't have things hanging around that
you're not using
go actually enforces that i already
talked a little bit about the baked in
concurrency
it's so uh just kind of
a few a few keywords and a few concepts
and hey i've got concurrent application
uh there's another thing which is
deferred calls
and this is kind of like a finally in a
try finally block in the c-sharp world
but
it kind of has a feature that i like
that's a little better than that
air handling in the go world is
completely different
than sharp and i'm not going to dive
into this but if you head out to the
resources
i do have an article that i wrote on
this in more in depth
basically and go and air is a glorified
string
so there isn't this exception handling
mechanism where
you know there's try catch blocks and if
you don't catch it it walks up the call
stack and looks for something
none of that exists so basically we're
passing these error messages around
and deciding how we're going to deal
with them go does have something that
is known as a panic which is for truly
bad situations like
reading beyond the end of an array or
something like that
something that's generally considered
dangerous or writing to a closed channel
and in those situations a panic behaves
like an unhandled exception the
application will exit there's no way to
catch it no way to stop it
so those are our two options in the go
world
something else that i found really
interesting is that
you can have multiple return values from
functions
and this is not using tuples like we
might in the c-sharp world this is
actually
just like you can have multiple
parameters you can have multiple return
values
and again that's something that's
interesting another thing is how
interfaces are handled i have
a soft spot for interfaces in the
c-sharp world and that's because it was
difficult for me to learn
as a junior programmer and became really
useful to me
in my day-to-day programming in fact i
have a pluralsight course on c-sharp
interfaces
that's how near and dear to me they are
go approaches interfaces in a really
interesting way through
implicit implementation which is kind of
cool
and we're going to look at that as well
so that's enough talking about slides
let's head over to code
and let me show you what we're going to
build and uh we'll look at
things from there so i'm going to flip
over to windows terminal
and i have some powershell tabs already
lined up here
if you do grab the repo then
there's two folders there's an async
folder and that's where we're going to
be writing our go code
and then there's another folder that
which is net people service
this is actually a net 5 service
and we're going to be consuming the
service
in our application so
let me flip over to my second tab this
is navigated to that.net service i'm
going to type in.net run just to fire it
up
and we'll take a look at what that does
let me head to my browser
and hit refresh here and the url that we
have
see if i can make that a little bigger
for you
is localhost and i have a custom port
people slash one so this is the end
point that i'm hitting
i'm saying hey go to your people
collection give me
id number one and uh
in this case there's about a dozen
values that are coming
that are available from this service
now i have the completed application
already in this tab
and i'll just run it so we can see what
it does
so first it prints out a list of here's
the ids i'm going to fetch from the
service
and then we get the values coming out of
that service
now one thing that's kind of interesting
about this is that
the service has an artificial delay
built into it
so each time i request one of these
items there's a one second delay on the
server side
and that's to simulate a little bit of
real world and in this case you notice
they all come up
kind of together and it takes a little
over a second to run
all nine of these requests and that's
because we're doing it concurrently
and so uh that's what we're going to do
today
so i'll head back over to my
tab that has the uh root of the
repo and uh navigate to the async folder
and if i look in this folder it is
currently empty
so i'm going to start by just creating a
new
go code file and i'll be using visual
studio code today
and the file will be called main dot go
and i will pop this open visual studio
code is a great editor for this
and visual studio code is also
cross-platform so that makes it handy
one thing that makes it such a great
editor for go
is that there is a plug-in uh an
extension i should say that's available
for go
and this does linting as well as code
completion
and pop-up help and all that other fun
stuff
now i just want to know you'll you might
notice here that i it's saying hey you
want to update your go
extension well this extension
updated automatically two days ago and
um i think there's a clash with the
version of go that i'm actually running
on my machine
because some of the code completion
was coming out weird so i actually
downgraded
my go extension for this demo okay
so let's go ahead and do hello world
right we have to start with hello world
now go has everything in go is in a
package
and so we can think of a package as it's
somewhere between an assembly and a
namespace
so it's a unit of
stuff and uh
for an application the entry point for
an application
it has to be in package main and there's
a function
called funcma function should say funk
main
which is in package main and that
defines the entry point of the
application
so we'll do a funk main and
get started here so this is kind of
about as empty of an application as you
can get
i want to point out a few things here uh
so
the main function that we have has a set
of empty parentheses
that represents parameters and in this
case main does not take parameters
so if you're used to doing a console
application for example
in net where
you know you'll have parameters which
are arguments from the command line
if you want to get arguments from the
command line there is something in the
os package where you can get to those
arguments
i won't be showing that today but that's
how you would get to them since they're
not passed in directly
one other thing is you'll notice that
the opening curly brace is
on the same line as the function
opening curly braces must be on the same
line
and this is enforced by the compiler
so like i said go is very opinionated
about things this is the one of the
things it's opinionated about
and for anyone who's done javascript and
has run into
the situation where if you don't have
the opening brace on the same line
and you get that empty return value
thing
you understand how valuable this is
okay so i want to print something to the
console
and there's a print function that i can
use but i need to bring in another
package
for that and so this would be you know
similar to bringing in
a a namespace slash assembly in the
c-sharp world
and a lot of times what i'm used to
doing in c-sharp is saying well
i want to use a package instead of
saying
using we'll say import
and the package i want is the format
package or fmt
so since i'm used to kind of typing and
using statements at the top of my screen
i might say okay well i'm going to put
all my imports at the top and then start
using them
well there's a problem and it's not a
problem once you get used to it
and that is go again doesn't like unused
things in your application
and in fact the linter um will
do some things for you so watch what
happens when i save this file i'll hit
ctrl s
and my import statement went away so
uh when i first started doing this i was
really frustrated because i'm like okay
import import import import
and then i saved it because i'm always
interim saving
and everything went away and what i
learned was
let it go because the compiler or i
should say
the um the go extension will take care
of some things for me
so if i want to use something from the
format package i can type fm
fmt dot and we'll use print
line print ln and now what happens
if i save it brings in the import for me
so rather than managing imports myself
i am going to let this all happen
kind of automatically okay so there's
print line function that goes out to the
standard out which is console by default
and we can put a hello world in there
and let's build this application
so building from the command line uh you
just say go
build and i'm not using a
any kind of debugging and visual studio
code just because
i haven't gotten it to work in all
honesty so
i do my building and running from the
command line
now let's see what we have in our folder
so we have our main.go file that's the
code file that we just typed in and then
you'll see i have an async.exe
now since i'm on windows it is a exe if
i was in a different operating system it
would be an executable file
and you'll notice the size of that file
is kind of big
and that's because this has everything
that it needs to run this application
so there's no runtime there's nothing
that's required to
install on a particular machine so i
could take this async.exe file
put it on a windows machine and it will
run
assuming you know there's always
architecture and other things
you know x64 versus 32-bit and whatnot
uh but that is a complete application
all on its own and if we run it
hello world so uh hopefully not too many
surprises so far
uh one other thing that i'll point out
is in the code on line six you'll notice
there are
no semicolons so if you're used to
typing semicolons
that's something you can get unused to
the nice thing is that if you do
type semicolons when you hit save they
generally go away
semicolons can be used to separate if we
want multiple statements
on a single line for example with a 4
which we'll see a little bit later
but generally leave them out
okay so um
i'm going to uh show how to do some
variable as
uh creations and assignments so i'm
going to create
an array to hold the ids
that i want to um that i want to look up
from this service
and so i'll i'll say ids
colon equals and the colon equals
is a creation and assignment for a
variable
so it works a lot like var in the
c-sharp world
so depending on what i put on the right
side of this equals that will be the
type
of this ids variable
now as i mentioned earlier go is
strongly typed it's just that it will
implicitly type it based on what we have
okay so here's how you declare an inter
a
so square brackets first saying hey this
is going to have nine elements in it
and then we can also initialize it with
a set of curly braces so
just like that so we'll put nine values
in there
and you'll notice that i have
red squigglies uh get used to red
squigglies
if i hover over this it's going to say
ids is declared
and not used and if i try to build
compiler error so i promised you a
compiler error if you have
a variable you declare and don't use
oh man get used to it
but we'll go ahead and put this in here
and now we can build it and we will
output
that value
so in here we see that we have those
numbers separated by spaces
in square brackets this is a default
output format for um
for an integer array or actually for any
array it would come out in that format
and we'll talk a little bit more about
default formats in just a bit
okay now that we've done this
let's actually make a service call if i
flip back to my service
uh i have this person object and it's a
collection of properties
there's some strings and integers and a
date time in there in the middle
somewhere
so i'm going to create a
type that will have those values in it
that we can use
so let's create a new type and for this
we will say type person struct because
this will be a struct
and then we can put in the fields that
we'll be using here
now something that's interesting about
go is that capitalization is important
again opinionated so you'll notice that
my
uh my type person starts with a
lowercase p
my function main starts with a lowercase
m
if something starts with a lower case
it's internal to this package
if something starts with an uppercase
level it is exported
from this package so if i were to look
in the fmt package
then i would see this print line
function in there
starts with a capital letter p so it's
exported which means if somebody imports
this package they can use
it so starting with a lower case
kind of similar-ish to private slash
protected in the c-sharp world
if something starts with a capital then
it is
um public okay
so let's create some fields so we'll
create an id field which is an int
a given name which is a string a family
name
which is also a string a start date
which is a time dot time
and a rating which is an integer
now a couple things i want to show here
watch what happens when i save
okay first of all it brought in another
import for the time package
but it lined up my um
my types for my fields so that's
something that
it's just doing for me so
uh and then um in these declarations
you'll notice that the type comes second
so the name comes first the type comes
second
okay so now that we have something to
put
or a type to put these values into
let's make a service call i'll make a
new function
we'll call it get person and this will
take an id of integer
or an id parameter that is an integer
and i'm going to return two values
so i mentioned how in go we can have
multiple return values
and that's baked into the language and
the return values come after the
parameters
so when we're talking about declaring a
function
we have the func keyword then the name
of the function
then the parameters in parentheses and
if there's
no parameters then empty parentheses and
then
a set of return values or return types
and then the opening curly brace if we
only have
one return type then we don't need
parentheses around it
and if we don't have any return types we
don't need any parentheses
as a reminder down on line 20 our func
main
no return type so we just kind of
don't mention that at all excuse me
okay so
what i need to do is call
this url and
put our own value into it so
i'm going to use another function
from the um
the format package so fmt s print
f
and then we will paste in our our url
because i want to parameterize this so
rather than having a hard-coded 3
i would like the id value in here
now this does use a
a format that's very similar to string
dot format in the c-sharp world
so we have placeholders which are called
verbs in go
the percent d is for um
for an integer value um we'll also see
percent s and percent v a little bit
later
and this is how we can uh generate
uh strings so there's a lot of
printf functions in the format package
printf means you know print something
that's formatted
so it potentially has these verbs in it
s printf will print to a string
f printf will print to a file or
more appropriately anything that
supports an i o writer
and then there's just a printf that will
go out to the console
and so you'll kind of see this pattern
as a common thing
in go okay so that creates a url that we
can use
let's make a service call and there's an
http package that has a
get function on it and again i'll save
and
on line five it brought in net slash
http
i actually find myself saving quite a
bit because
that's how you get the good help
so the pop-ups happen better if you're
saving
so we can see that the get function
takes a
string for a url so we'll put that value
in there
now what's interesting here is this
returns two values
it returns a pointer to a response and
an
error and this is a very similar
um this is a pretty common convention
for how to write your functions you'll
notice that this get person
i'm returning a person and an error so
the idea is that if this completes
successfully
the person value will be filled in and
error will be
nil which is the equivalent of null in
the c-sharp world
and so basically what we're doing is
we're getting an error as
one of the return values that we can
then check to see
if it's populated or not
now for getting these values out you
know i can say okay well here's response
set equal to the get
but this returns two values
both the um pointer to the response and
an
error well you can assign both of those
values
based on by just comma separating some
variable names
so in this case resp will be a pointer
to a response
if i hover over this it should show that
yes
and er is an error
and again those are uh like vars in the
c-sharp world
but these are in fact separate values as
opposed to
like a deconstructed uh tuple
and actually have an article that talks
about that as well
so if you want more details on multiple
return values
there's resources on my website
so uh we should check to see if the
error is populated before we go on
so i'll check to see if the error is not
nil now when we're talking about if
conditions
fairly similar to the c-sharp world one
difference is there's no parentheses
around the condition itself
so er not equal to nil is just there
there's no
parentheses uh the curly brace again on
the
same line as the if another thing is
that
those curly braces are not optional if
you only have
one line you must have them they must be
there
so again opinionated which is good
because it gets rid of some ambiguity
now in this case what i've done is i've
said
if there's an error i'm going to return
an empty person
and the same error object unfortunately
i won't have time to show you doing
custom error messages today
but again i've got a link on my on the
resources that talk about error handling
in much more detail for now we'll just
check to see if the error
is populated and if so we will uh
return it this uh layout this way of
doing things is pretty common where if
we hit an error we actually
short circuit the function so generally
not an if else situation it's usually if
this is true
you know exit out go do something else
so again
kind of um that's a convention that's
not actually enforced
um but uh it's out there
okay so now that i have a response
that's coming back
i want to parse it and for this we'll
use
a json decoder now there is a json
package which is nice
so i can say new decoder and again i'll
hit
save just so that i've got my help
populating nicely
and this is a function that takes an i o
reader
as a parameter and our response object
has a body and if i look at this
it it says it's a read closer so this
actually
implements both the i o reader interface
and the i o
closer interface so we can use that to
say hey
jason go ahead and decode what's in uh
this i o reader and then i can say dot
decode
and tell it what i want to do with
the decoded the the decoded values
now one thing that's interesting about
this decode function is if we look at
the parameter
it says it is interface that has empty
curly braces
well this represents an empty interface
so it's an interface that has no members
in
it now because of the way go works with
implicit implementation of interfaces
which again we'll see
that a little more in person in just a
moment
what this means is that this matches
any type so the equivalent of this in
the c-sharp world would be
object so if a function takes an object
we can put anything we want in here
if a function takes an empty interface
we can put any type that we want in
there
and it will match that interface
now one thing that we do have to do is
we have to get into pointers a little
bit
let me create a variable that we can use
to decode our values into
now so far we've been declaring our val
our variables with
the colon equals which creates the value
or i should say declares it and assigns
a value to it
you can declare a variable using the var
keyword
and in this case it's var then the name
p and then the type
person now what i pass into this
is actually ampersand p
so i mentioned that go does have
pointers
i'm sorry for those of you who thought
you left pointers behind
uh it's actually don't think of this as
c pointers though because again
memory safety is something that is baked
into go it was one of the design
principles
but in this case decode does not return
a person it actually returns an error
so in order to get the values out
we need to modify the parameter that's
coming in
so to be able to modify that parameter i
pass the
address of that parameter using the
ampersand
into the decode and now it's able to
modify
that particular variable if i were to
just pass
p in there it could use the values but
it could not
modify it i mean it could modify them
internally but it wouldn't be persistent
outside of the function so um kind of
like
an out in c-sharp but it's a little more
nuanced
than that so it can actually assign
these values okay and since this returns
an error
i'll go ahead and pick that up and we'll
just use our
a similar error block to what we used
above
and then if everything is happy
we will just return a person oh actually
we'll return person and
nil since we have two return values
so this is the code that we need to get
a value from a service and i like that
it's
fairly um you know there's not a whole
lot to it
which i like and there's a lot of things
built in
like the http functions are all there
the json decoders there
so um you know it kind of feels nice
to start with okay so let's use our
newly found power
in our main method and i'll start by
hard coding
the value so we'll say get person and
i'll pass in
an id of three and in fact
we'll say person error and then we'll do
a format
dot printf and we'll say percent
d percent v
p dot id and p
okay and one thing i always forget to do
with print
uh printfs is there's no new line
automatically on there
so backslash n for a new line
and what we have for this format string
again percent d is a verb that means
integer so i'm going to print out
the um the id
in fact let's put a colon after it and
then percent
v is a verb that stands for the
natural format and we can really think
of this as a two string
i could use a percent s and it would
have pretty much the same effect
uh what we have for a struct is it will
print out all of the values of all of
the fields
that's the default way that structs work
now you'll see i have red squigglies
and it says hey you're not using this
error variable
well i'll come back and use this later
but for now
i'm going to skip over it and i can use
an underscore for that so an underscore
is a it's known as a blank identifier
and go
but it's a disc it's a discard so if i'm
not going to use a value
then i can skip over it i wouldn't
recommend
skipping over errors but
it is possible and will be
slash async so now if we run this
now we get our values out and
it looks like i got a forward slash n
instead of a backslash n at the end of
that so
good job jeremy okay so
backslash n uh but what we can see
is we've got the curly braces with all
of the values of the fields
printed out now i want to change that i
want it to have a different
default output and in c-sharp we would
say oh well everything descends from
object so just override the two-string
method and you're good to go
well uh go doesn't have that
but it does have an interface that is
used
which is called the stringer interface
and so we'll see how interfaces work for
this now
when i'm looking things up online i will
say like uh golang
fmt uh golang gives you better search
results than go
fmt is the name of the package that i'm
looking for and generally hit golang.org
with the documentation that you want so
that's a good way of searching
i'm going to hit the index and scroll
down to type stringer
and we'll take a look at this
so stringer is an interface
and just like interfaces in the c-sharp
world they have methods
and in this case there's one method
which is called string
with an uppercase s takes no parameters
and returns a string
now i kind of mentioned earlier that go
has
implicit implementation for interfaces
what that means is that i do not need to
mark my struct
and say hey my struct is a stringer
i don't actually say that directly at
all
what i do instead is i implement
the string method on my struct
and it automatically implements that
interface
so it has implicit implementation of of
interfaces which is
a really interesting topic that i've
been
exploring as i've come across different
things in my programming
okay so let's create a func a named
string that returns a string
okay well we have a little bit of a
problem here
because i need to associate this with
the person struct
somehow now you can't put methods into a
struct so unlike c sharp i can't add a
method directly to this strut
but what i can do is between the func
and the string the function name i can
add a um
a variable and a type
and this is uh this associates
this string method with the person
struck
so oh and man
i'm totally having a brain freeze
because
i forgot what that that actually that
thing is called
it's a method
okay i'll get back to you on that
unfortunately my brain froze up
okay so this is a method
now in c sharp we kind of use the terms
function and method a little
interchangeably
uh people in the f-sharp and functional
programming world have much
clearer definitions in the go world a
func
a function is something that is not
associated with a type
so in this case uh function main on line
36 is a function
the get person on line 10 is a function
but on line 32
this string is a method because it
belongs to the person
type and then in here
i can say return fmt.s
printf and let's give it a percent as
percent
s and we'll pass in the
given name and the family name
so here's what's really cool about this
and i think it's really cool because if
i look at this
all i did was add this method and if i
rebuild my application and then run it
now it comes out in a completely
different format so it comes out in the
format that i want
so the implicit implementation of
interfaces
i find it really interesting because all
i did was add a string method
and it's like oh well there's an
interface that matches that and
my percent v format verb is going to use
that
um so i might get over excited about
that but i get over excited about
interfaces
in general so
uh okay uh
let's do a little bit of looping because
loops are always important
right now i just have a hard-coded value
but i kind of like to go through all of
these ids
now in the c-sharp world we have a lot
of ways to do it we have a four
we have a four-each we have a do a while
we have a do-while in go you have a four
that's all you have the good news is you
can use a whole bunch of conditions
uh different condition types that
actually covers the functionality
of all of the different loop types that
we have in c sharp
let's start by using an indexer so we'll
say
like a typical for loop so i equals zero
i less than lang ids
and len is a built-in length function
and then i plus plus so
hopefully this code is not terribly
frightening
and then instead of passing this in
we'll say
ids i will index into
our array
so go build and now when we run the
application
we'll get all of those values coming
back now like i mentioned there is a one
second delay that's built
into the service and that's why these
are clicking back slowly
we will get to the concurrency in just a
bit
but we can see all of our values come
out now
i don't like four i like four each four
4-h is awesome
in c-sharp well there's an equivalent of
4 each using the for loop and go
first we'll modify the way this indexer
works because
using an indexer that iterates through
you know however long
something is is common well instead of
doing all of this
i can say range ids and this will have
the same effect
so it will index it will
the i will be an index based on the
range
or i'm sorry the about based on the
number of items
in the array and um
and it will actually work exactly the
same way i know we've known each other
for 40 minutes but i don't expect you to
trust me fully
but you can see it does in fact do the
same thing we just saw
now what's more interesting than this is
range can take
can return two values and in this case
i is an indexer so against zero through
eight in this case id will be the actual
value
the one two three four five six seven
eight nine so
very much like the value that's coming
out of a four
each so instead of saying ids i
i can say id and this saves me from
having to
index back into that array again
so rather than you know iterating
through the
basically iterating the array and then
pulling each value out
i can say oh you know give me that id
value
now again it'll say i is not being used
at this point
but a blank identifier takes care of
that
and again we'll just we'll just kind of
do a build and a run
and see that we get exactly the same
results
do you trust me yet maybe
okay so
kind of the next step i want to do is i
want to
run these things concurrently because
this is taking too long
and in fact to see how long it is i'll
just add
a couple of um variables here so at the
top we'll say start
equals time dot now so that will give me
the current time and then down here i'll
create an elapsed
variable and the time package has a
sense
function and so i can say time sense
start and this will give me
a duration and a duration
actually kind of prints out nicely ish
in the standard format so we'll say
format.printf
and we'll say total time
percent v elapsed
go build
and let's do a clear and then
run this
and now we'll i'll actually wait for it
to finish this time so that we can see
the total time
at the end and nine seconds is a really
long time
okay so there we can see we've got 9.09
seconds coming out of this
okay now i want to
run this get person concurrently
so rather than doing something
one value at a time i'd like to
you know kind of like think about
running this as a task in c-sharp right
i want to
run these all at the same time and we
can definitely do that and go again
concurrency is baked in
and in fact it's called a go routine
that's how important it is
go routines uh the name of the language
that's how important these are
now one thing about this is now it gets
complicated because how do you return
something from a go routine well rather
than
kind of having um you know continuations
and
the interesting things that we have in
task and the await and so forth
that makes up async await
there's a few different approaches we
can use like a shared
value uh that can be read from
uh different contexts uh something that
is also part of the language is known as
a channel
and you can think of a channel as a
concurrent queue
so it's a concurrent friendly cue so i
can have an
asynchronous operation that's adding
things to the channel
and then i can read off of that channels
somewhere else
and so that's what we'll use today
for this i will uh create a wrapper
around this get person more or less and
i'm really bad at coming up with names
so the best name that
i have right now is fetch person2
channel
and i i apologize for that name and this
will take an id
oh it'll actually take an id and a
channel
and we'll call the channel ch and
uh we'll we'll use this interesting
syntax
for that and this actually won't return
any values
so here i have a channel and chan
specifies the type
channels also have to have a type
associated with them that says this is
what this channel will hold
so channel can only hold one type and in
this case we have a channel of
person now that little arrow that's
pointed
towards the chan that's indicating that
this function
is it's only going to be writing to the
channel
so uh you can read from a channel right
from a channel do a read and write from
the channel
but in this case we're specifying hey
i'm only going to be writing to this
channel
and that gives the compiler chances to
optimize things
a little bit better and so
let's take the code that we have here
we'll cut that paste it up here
and then to write to the channel
we use a skinny arrow as opposed to a
fat arrow
so what this will do is it will take
that value p
and put it on to the channel
and i'm not comfortable
with ignoring the errors but i want to
make sure i get through the rest of this
concurrency
and i'll go pick up that error if i have
time that underscore on line 37 is
really bothering me right now if you do
go look at the downloaded code that's on
github
it does have full air handling so
um again this is kind of the quick tour
okay and
this is one way of handling this
um what i'm going to do is create
two loops i'm going to create a loop
that will put values
onto a channel and another loop that
will
read values from the channel
okay let's get rid of that code
and outside of these loops i'll create a
channel variable
so to create a channel there's another
built-in function
in go which is called make and this is
used to
to make channels as well as maps which
is like a dictionary
and also slices which you'll want to
read about slices it's kind of a
it's a view into an array and it's very
common in go
so i'll specify that i want to channel a
person and then also how big i want the
channel to be
in this case i'll say this channel is
capable of holding
10 elements this is important because if
i leave this blank
this channel a channel by default has a
capacity of one
so if i write to the channel and then
something else tries to write to the
channel
it will block that operation until
somebody first reads that value off of
the channel
so depending on what you need that might
work fine
in our case i want to be able to put a
chunk of values onto the channel
so that i can read them off somewhere
else
so i'll create a capacity of 10.
blocking gets
interesting and i don't have an article
on this yet but
i am going to have one very shortly
okay so for this we will call the fetch
person to channel we'll pass from the id
and the channel
and then to make this asynchronous we
add go
and so now this uh fetch person to
channel
will uh kick off uh concurrently
and this loop will keep going so it
won't wait the one second
for the get person to complete it will
just keep going
so these will run pretty much in
parallel
okay to read values off of the channel i
can create a variable and again i'll use
the colon equals to create and assign
and use the arrow coming off
of the channel like that
now in this case what i'm doing is i'm
going to
on line 48 i'm writing to the channel a
certain number of time based on the
ids that i have on line 53 i'm reading
from the channel that same number of
times based on the ids
but i'm not actually using the values
that are coming out so it says hey
ids is declared but not used so you
don't want to do that
so another blank identifier uh
no it doesn't like this either
because it says hey there's no variables
on the left side of this assignment
operator
well it turns out you can leave that out
entirely
so if you say four range ids then this
will loop
the number of times in this case nine
times based on how many elements are in
the ids
array in this case but there's no
values i don't have an indexer or a
value coming out
this is not the best way to handle this
but i kind of i want to show you
asynchrony
without going into all of the details
because we only have nine minutes left
now if you do want some more information
again check out the resources
because the sample code that's out there
uses something that's known as a weight
group
and a weight group is it's basically a
reference counter
so i can say okay whenever i
kick off this asynchronous process i'm
going to add one
to a weight group variable and then
up here when this process is complete
i'm going to subtract one from the
weight group
and then there's a weight group.weight
function that you can use and it will
block so nothing will run below it until
that weight group
hits zero and so in that case what i'd
really want to do
is close the channel at that point and
rather than
reading the ids a certain number of time
i would just keep reading from the
channel until it's closed
so again something i don't really have
time to show you today but something
that
gets a little more complicated than what
we have here but what we have here
fingers crossed should be enough to get
the um concurrent operations going
okay i'm feeling very confident fingers
crossed
hey look at that tada
okay uh applause applause applause
okay it's a little difficult when
everybody's on mute but
okay i get the general idea but we can
see up here
our time when we were doing things
non-concurrently nine seconds
down here concurrently one second
so all of these operations are running
at the same time you know as much as
that's true in the computer world
now just like a lot of parallel
programming when you get into
concurrency things become
non-deterministic
so if you notice the order that these
ids are coming out in
they're not coming out in any particular
order and if i run this again
they'll come out in a different order so
if that's important to you you might
need to do a little more
a little more work but uh it's
a standard um a standard thing we have
to deal with when it comes to
concurrency
okay so um
oh and uh richard evans was actually
paying attention
uh when i was talking about methods
earlier
and i just saw it in the chat so line 32
this p person this is called a method
receiver
thank you yes that is the term that i
was searching my head for
so uh thank you for that richard okay
so um
i am not going to go back and add
better error handling at this point i
will leave that as an exercise
uh for the viewer but what i will do
is i want to show you
um something that's kind of interesting
okay so if you do go out to
the repository go for the c sharp dev
um this actually has something that is
known as a code tour
and a code tour is an extension for
visual studio
and you'll see there's a tours folder
here that's part of the repo
let me show you what that means uh let
me just
pull up
this code in visual studio code
with code
and let's see
and then if you uh scroll through this
code i talked about
weight groups so that's in here uh
there's also
the weight and closing the channel and
doing things some different ways
now if you do have an extension and
again you can come in here and type in
code tour
and you'll find the code tour extension
available
you'll see that in my explorer i have a
code tour
tab and i have three tours that are set
up here and if you click this little
start tour
arrow this will walk you through the
code
and have annotations for it so here it's
pointing at package main that we saw at
the beginning
talks a little bit about that here we're
looking at
funk main talks a little bit about funk
mate
uh where the curly braces go and a lot
of the things that we talked about today
so this code tour is available
by just again getting the repo and
installing that code tour extension so
and this goes into more detail than i
had time to show you
and then another thing is that down at
the bottom in the resources
there are um some articles written
again kind of from the perspective of a
c-sharp developer how are things
different
uh loops how do all the for loops work
and go
defer which i actually skipped over
i'm sorry i skipped over to fur that's
really cool
air handling this is an article that
talks all about the air handling
philosophy that's in go uh the multiple
return values which are
similar to uh tuples and c sharp but
they're actually different um and then i
do have some more articles that i have
planned
for this series as well so there's a lot
more out there
in fact let's see how close i came
okay so with today's topic we did see
the very opinionated syntax
where you put your curly braces things
like that unused variables actually
result in compile errors
uh baked in concurrency go routines are
there deferred calls which
i totally skipped over and i apologize
for that error handling
again a different philosophy of error
handling where
as a programmer we take a little bit
more of a hands-on approach
checking error return values we saw
multiple return values and we saw
interfaces with the stringer interface
there are a lot more topics so again
this is a very quick tour
uh talking about how packages work i can
write custom code and bring in a package
like a library
how exports worked i talk a little bit
about the capitalized versus not
capitalized
project structure types interfaces in
more detail
named return values you can actually put
a name on your return type uh
in in addition to just the type and bear
returns go along with that
the code tour actually mentions those uh
the difference between errors and panics
pointers inline go routines which is an
anonymous
function that has closures there's a lot
a lot of really cool stuff out there
okay and again here's the links
uh let me just check to see if we have
any
i have not been keeping a good
look at the slack
and it looks like there's no questions
on either side so um
in the slack and in the
chat it looks like i'm caught up which
is kind of interesting
uh if you do have questions that come up
later
feel free to drop me an email again i'm
an explorer in this space but it is
interesting to think about
hmm maybe i can use this to start
writing
my primary language a little bit
differently and if you go out to my
website jeremybites.com you will find a
link
to the github repo as well so if you
lose track of that github repo
i am jeremy bites on github as well as
well as on twitter
and so with that i say thank you very
much for spending this hour with me
and there's one session left of
ndc so enjoy the last
session and thank you very much for
joining me
you